all right d
oh i need to connect my headphones
okay let's play king's indian
okay we're gonna play king's indian
defense now the king's indian defenses
i've explained many times
uh the point is that you basically give
up
control of the center and in return
you develop pieces to attack the center
from a distance
in order to make the king's indian work
properly you need to first complete your
development quickly so let's castle
and now the time for the time has come
to well the knight from f3
defends the fun on g4 so what comes to
mind
in terms of attacking that pawn on d4
directly or indirectly there are several
several ways of accomplishing this
you could play bashu g4 right you could
you could trade this bishop for the
night and soften up white's defense
over the d4 pawn this is not a typical
king's indian move but
uh it does illustrate one of the key
themes now a lot of people here would
take the knight but there's no hurry
because we have the night pinned we
could take him at a moment of our
convenience thank you hisholina for the
raid so how should we
continue to press on this pawn on d4
with our pieces
in the spirit of this line which is to
use pieces
to pressure the center from a distance
c5 is possible we can strike with the
pawn
but let's use our pieces thank you so
much he selena hi selena for the 75
party raid he's castled
so he simply ignores the threats that we
have posed on his center
so we can take on d4 because of the pin
he cannot take back
and uh he's essentially bust i mean
busted he lost the central pawn
and now he makes matters worse by taking
on f6
now if we were extra fancy here uh what
would we do
in this position we can take on well we
can take on f6 with the bishop we can
take back but
what intermediate move can we also
consider making
yeah so a lot of you guys got caught in
the trap when you make a move such as
knight takes f3 you have to calculate it
make an intermediate move you have to
calculate it if you play knight takes f3
allow gf
then that pawn from f3 is going to
attack the bishop on g4
and uh we're going to lose a piece so
believe it or not we play bishop takes
f3
he pl he plays pawn takes f3 he doesn't
attack anything
now we can take on f6 and we have ruined
the structure around his king
now we are also now we are also
up upon his king side is ruined
and we can exploit either the first
thing or the second thing
uh it really depends on what we want to
do now one
approach that a lot of people struggle
with is the queen side attack
uh it's it's hard for black to do
anything specific on the king's side yet
yeah but we're going to keep that in
mind unless
you guys have any ideas in terms of
activating pieces and you guys do which
is queen d7
now there was also an idea of pressuring
the queen side but let's go for the
brute force approach
let me just write this down especially
because he's ignored completely the
threats
so what do we do here
what do we do in this position yeah we
win as queen because
there is no stopping checkmate on h2
bishop e5 by the way would have been
worse and
very important to indicate that in such
situations there is often only one
correct option and you have to operate
under that assumption
okay so let's see tommy queen takes f1
exactly
okay he's resigned okay so first things
first
why is the move bishop e5
worse in this position why does this not
lead to checkmate
inevitably checkmate on h2 it is worse
because
white can play f4 now you have to
remember
a very crucial thing i call this the
three ways of stopping a threat
and numbers two and three people forget
about
all the time let's say that a peace or a
pawn
is threatened you're attacking a knight
you're attacking upon what are the ways
of defending against
this threat the first is to move
that piece or that pawn and to shift it
to a different location
sorry four ways to defend against a
piece or a pawn uh there that you
move it to a different location okay
obvious the second is to defend it with
another piece or a pawn
so those two methods are very obvious to
people but the third and the fourth are
not
the third is to intercept one of the
attackers
the third is to intercept one of the
attackers i think it's called
interference
so you interfere with the bishop's
control over h2
and then the fourth what is most
commonly forgotten about
is setting an est equal or stronger
threat
by which you refer to a threat that
obviously is equal in value or even
stronger so if your knight is attacked
and you respond to that threat by
attacking your opponent's queen
you are setting an est and every time
one of your pieces or fonts is
threatened you don't need to go down the
checklist and like see
okay can i apply method three can i
apply method four
generally the solution presents itself
intuitively but if you're in a situation
where you don't
see a defense against the threat
remember to kind of look
under the under the third and fourth
categories because there
you can you can find some stuff that
otherwise your brain would not have
indicated
okay method five is resign method five
is just to not
move the piece and just to allow it
obviously
but i'm mostly talking about pairing the
threat okay
now in terms of the game itself
in terms of the game itself i've already
introduced
uh king's indian concepts now in the
mainline kings indian generally
black plays the move e5 and you will see
this for example in the main line of the
king's indian
uh which is referred to knight f3
castles bishop two this is called the
classical variation or the main line
black plays e5 to strike in the center
and uh this is not upon blunder because
if fight takes twice on e5
then the king's indian bishop comes into
play and what is the way to win the pawn
back
with interest uh the king's indian
hinges on
this very tactic working otherwise the
whole king's indian would be invalidated
knight takes c4 exposing the attack on
the knight
now you might study this position
carefully and say wait a second
we have a situation with two hanging
pieces i have talked about this
situation before in a situation where
you have two hanging pieces you need to
look for a desperado with one of the
pieces where
you give that piece away for as much as
you can and then you take the other
piece
so here the move knight takes f7 comes
to mind it seems to win a pawn
because if you now take this knight then
white will take yours
and white will be up upon but the
reality is knight takes f7
loses a piece it loses a piece because
black has an intermediate move
or more precisely two intermediate moves
so one of them is the more meaningful
one
can anybody spot how black wins a piece
here yeah
you simply play bishop takes c3 now you
can swap the queens
just to eliminate the fluff you take the
knight and then this knight on e4 is
unharmed
this is actually a very important
variation
that justifies the existence of the
king's indian so
here you might ask why did i not play e5
and if you compare
this position to this position you'll
see that instead of the bishop on e2
there is a bishop on g5
that bishop is creating a potential pin
this pin becomes a reality if i play e5
and this is a very unpleasant thing to
allow
because very simply white can play
knight d5
or white can even play bishop takes f6
bishop takes f695 and white wins
because it's a fork on f6 and on c7
black cannot save both things at the
same time and he is losing
so that is why you have to be very
flexible in the opening
you cannot put your head down and
dogmatically make
the same moves regardless of your
opponent's opening
scheme you have to look at what he's
played and you have to decide
accordingly uh what you play
so knight so that's why we decided on
bishop g4 knight c6 a more concrete
approach
a piece based approach toward attacking
d4
uh yes is ac if you landed in the
situation you were trying to make the
most of it you would you would take on
d5
and um you know you can you can try to
coordinate your pieces although this is
very bad because white also gets
his rook to c1 uh and so
his rook also has immediate prospects
um okay so for that reason
uh e5 is bad and so we decided to do
this
now he castled that was very bad he
should have probably played d5
as babzin is indicating and then i would
have played knight e5
uh and uh remember to always
well exploit the pin i mean otherwise
why are you pinning your opponent's
pieces
if he drops his bishop back to e2 we can
take on f3
now if he takes of the bishop he drops a
pawn so he has to take with a pawn
and now he's basically really
permanently weakened
both his king side and his center
and we can play c6 and deploy the queen
through b6 we have a very very good
position here
uh and a very big initiative because
white is nowhere to castle if he castles
king side his kingside is ruined if he
castles queen side
then the bishop on g7 is going to be
incredibly powerful
and it's going to be a very strong agent
of attack
um okay so this
is very good now he blundered upon we
made this intermediate move to ruin his
king side and then the last thing to
talk about
is if we did not want to play on
the king side and we wanted to play on
the queen side how could we have
done that well you know what's the thing
about playing on the queen side
uh people you know what i think people
should do is is
think of attacks on the king and attacks
on the queen side
in a similar way you think about
attacking the king
often you think about a pawn storm you
think about pawns
advancing forward and provoking
weaknesses in the opponent's position
and it's much the same with a queen side
attack except it can be a little bit
harder to prepare these pawn moves
hey hi selena and in this case
the move c6 comes to mind the idea of c6
is to play a6 and then to play
b5 expanding on the queen side so it's
sort of like a queenside pawn storm
except it takes a little bit longer to
prepare
yeah so it's it's a typical idea in the
king's indian actually
uh because yeah you'll see it in many
different types of positions
okay so this would have also been very
possible and
combined with the extra pawn block is in
terrific shape here
any questions
yeah the king's indian is not that hard
to learn
on an initial level but it's very hard
to master thank you tanto i'm very happy
to hear that thank you for the sub man
okay guys one last game because i'm
exhausted
i do have a recommendation for opening
theory
um i imagine that most of you happen to
own a copy of the uh
recent it's this is a recent book
uh the handbook the recent book
uh it's it's in german but i recommend
it so much i think you should get it
even though it's in german
it's pretty recent uh it's got analysis
of
the philidor
so it's got a lot of analysis actually
zooka tour did
call it outdated yesterday but
oh there's stein it's mentioned
but they made a new copy anyways um
okay so let's play this is the handbook
of openings
so it's an it's an opening book that was
originally published in like 1870
and i have the edition republished in
like 1910.
so yeah
anyways
potential endgame scenarios yes i'm
happy to
um i'm happy to
to talk about endgame scenarios
and i can do like a separate unit on
that on like basic checkmates or like
basic end games
but i've always felt that like that's
pretty well covered in chess literature
but if it's not
then i'm happy to cover it um so
it's the sort of thing that i assumed
you can find stuff on like basic end
games
and my one sort of precondition is i
don't want to do stuff that's like been
done
before well by other people i don't want
to steal their thunder
well i appreciate that felsberg
um knifeless bishop made of course i can
cover
but uh that is that is actually pretty
difficult to explain
in a systematic way but i think i have a
way
to do that it's called the handbook just
shock spiels
okay uh let's play one more game then
no i would recommend queen's gambit
initially and then king's indian maybe
like 1300 plus
yeah okay
so we have been playing the accelerated
dragon
in our latest couple of games in the
speedrun bishop c4 we already know
how to meet this pretty well ziggy
and we meet this by playing e6 blunting
the bishop and preparing to go d5
expanding in the center why not just get
an english translation dude i was
kidding
it's a historical artifact man
there's no english translation of this
150 year old book
so now we can just castle very simple
developmental moves
okay so he goes d4 so this guy is kind
of good
but there's no reason we should we
should take the pawn i mean let
him be the one to take our pawn
then our bishop can come out to c5 and
skewer his king so where should this
bishop on c8 go
tickle tickle mother
where should this bishop from c8 go it
should go to g4 in order to pin the
knight
to the queen and
now what should we do
we'll just take and go knight d4 so
obviously pins are great and you want to
keep them but if you can win like a
central pawn
you should that usually takes priority
now
let's go after this bishop for a second
hey gaines well i
and the reason i took is just to win the
pawn i mean i'm not doing anything
mysterious i'm just winning a pawn
now uh we would love to go c4
and actually miscalculated this detail
but queen takes d4 picks off the knight
i know some people are thinking of c4
probably
that's all good charles you're welcome
you're welcome always welcome so
how do we go about fixing the situation
well
one option when we mess up is just to
sort of make a move
uh that improves our position from a
general perspective
we don't we don't have to do anything
there's no threats so can we bring one
of our pieces into the game
okay there's a and it's a typical move
we make this move all the time we bring
this particular piece in the game all
the time
uh queen b6 drops the bishop on e7 so we
would go rookie
good job and um
that's something that i i advise to
people to
stabilize the situation when you made
something made a mistake by making a
gentle improvement he's made a blunder
i didn't stop to explain it but we take
on b3 and after he takes back what's the
next move
he's put his pieces on a forkable on
four couple squares we can go d4 and win
his bishop or his knight and we're going
to be a
full piece up and the game is going to
be over and he resigns simply good
nice and short so everything was very
simple we've had this many times before
we just developed our pieces
bishop h5 would have been possible to
keep the tension but we decided to go
after the pawn instead
um and we decided to go after the pawn
instead which is totally sensible now i
actually miscalculated i thought i had
c4
winning the bishop but he does take the
knight so
rather than panicking we just made a
general improving move waited for him to
feed us the rope to hang himself
yeah the pawn on d5 can be hard to
defend which is why
we're basically going for active
development if he takes
then we want to circumvent the weakness
of the pawn by attacking all of his
all of his vulnerabilities including the
pit including the pawn on f2
and um this is this is actually a nasty
position for white to play particularly
in blitz
because black has a lot of clearly
defined ideas
whereas white really doesn't so that's
sort of
the way of the land
[Music]
you